now with some real answers we're joined
exclusively by Larry Kudlow White House
chief economic adviser
Larry Congrats on these huge jobs
numbers like I've known you cried oh no
25 years I don't know if I ever thought
would sit here in a day like night like
tonight with 3.6 percent unemployment
numbers I mean this is
I'm sorry blows away our former boss
ronald reagan's numbers if you ask me
well I don't know that far but I will
say Carlos says Trump's recovery not as
good as Reagan no I don't want to say
that either what I'll say is this all
these blow out numbers get to the stats
in a moment but look president Trump's
policies to rebuild the economy have put
us into a powerful prosperity boom and
there is no end in sight
let's not make this any harder than it
needs to be low tax rates regulatory
rollback energy openings trade reforms
growth growth growth growth that's what
you got going here and these blowout
numbers okay - it's actually a bit about
a fortnight
it started with 3.2 percent GDP which no
one believed possible okay today two
hundred sixty-three thousand jobs beat
the street estimates by about seventy
thousand three point six percent
unemployment I was graduating from
college in late 1969 last time we had
three point six that's a long time Larry
the tight labor market I know there are
a lot of business people out there don't
like tight labor markets because that
mean wages are going up we have a tight
labor market and I was reading today in
the journal that Rockwell corporation
they actually have to true their
training veterans American veterans
advocates to do the jobs that need to be
done we bring it in foreign workers and
those a big push to bring in foreign
workers you don't need to be bringing in
foreign workers we still have a lot of
people on the sidelines so we're now
coming back into the economy I love that
story today so here's here's a great
part of the story one of the other
blowout numbers the other day was the
productivity output per hour how
efficient are we soaring to 2.4 percent
now to your point which is really good
we had a lot of people the estimates
vary there may be 25 million Americans
who have left the labor force altogether
more alive because they were discouraged
and demoralized they are coming back
they're coming back because the wage
rates are moving above 3% they're coming
back because their friends and neighbors
are going back to work and they're
coming back because these companies need
them and if you're not totally qualified
they will retrain you as my colleague
Ivanka Trump puts it they will Reese
kill you you can learn this stuff he's
really pushing that and I'm really glad
she is she's pushing that and it's kind
of like dismissed early on look at what
we're seeing we're seeing real average
higher wages higher wage just bring them
in I'm companies with like why are we I
mean everyone should be thrilled about
wages going up they went up a little bit
under Obama but now Orthodox mainstream
Washington economists higher wages are
bad they cause inflation it's jack up
interest rates nonsense more people
working and prospering and getting this
promise is what we need blue-collar
workers are the leaders the best wage
gains here's a stat for you don't draw
me in stats because some people lose
stats hit back at some of the critics
our friend Joe Biden my friend Joe Biden
said today the the middle class not
participating so get this the lower 25%
of the income earners their wages up
four and a half percent the upper 25 3
percent now they're both rising but
actually I love that tap or your other
friend
yes said this about why the booming
economy didn't lead his show tonight hmm
we were gonna lead with the economy on
the show it was going to be the first
block we're gonna sing the numbers that
we just sang and then President Trump
decided to talk to Vladimir Putin and
talk about how you know Russia hoax and
all that but he shouldn't lie with the
economy one last point wages booming
growth productivity more people employed
lower no inflation no in-place experts
predicted it they're predicting
recession right around the corner even
Bloomberg headline is no risk
shouldn't say so if there's no inflation
and a steady dollar we will continue the
president hitting on the fret all the
tarry low inflation and very low
interest rates and so the Fed you know
they're independent blah blah blah but
they're looking at the low inflation
numbers to very surprising we feel that
may give them grounds later and don't
soften up on China though I don't want
to hear any softening of China the China
policy is working I don't know softening
up on China the negotiators meaning with
leave hey this week from China are
scared to death of you so they're not
gonna back off fantastic we didn't trade
with the Soviet Union it's gotta be a
great deal let me just say it's got to
be a great deal with China must be in
u.s. MCA okay the old NAFTA 2.0 is a
great deal there could be a hundred
billion dollars of added GDP per year
with a hundred and eighty thousand jobs
per year if we get through us MCA Bob
light Houser did a hell of a good job
see this is know people won't give Trump
any any credit everything's converging
this is a powerful prosperity wave
because we changed all the incentives in
the economy argument Larry is basically
gonna be Trump is not a good person he
tweets too much he says s whole
countries they want people to ignore the
fact that the economy is great and just
focus on some of these other issues so
they're gonna make it like a personality
contest in that's what you see like Joe
Biden's using the word dignity a lot I
think there's a lot of dignity in these
numbers that you're citing tonight first
of all as somebody who is in and out of
his office every day I can tell you he
is a good person I want to say that he
is a good cushy life to do that to get
beat up every day is a decisive well
informed manager Executive Forum
businessman so that's terrific stuff but
but but but looking ahead to the
election we have an opportunity to
develop the biggest big tent economic
coalition in history probably
reminiscent of Reagan in 1984 the tax
cuts are working the deregulation is
working
trade is working income inequality and
they're all as the Democrats are setting
income inequality the cost of education
everything's new collar workers who are
doing the best their employment is the
fastest and their wages going up is the
fastest I don't I just want to sit down
with my Democratic friends and kind of
walk through these numbers because
that's what's their plan to raise the
standard of living in most Americans
well I'll tell you this I don't know
what their precise plan is haven't heard
much but for those Democrats who want to
go the socialist direction they could
turn this powerful prosperity cycle into
a major downturn poverty would win not
prosperity and so that's one of the big
themes here no to socialism put it on
trial and convicted because it's no good
health care for all all that stuff the
green New Deal
it will wreck this prosperity and let me
say one thing all right president is the
president of the entire economy and it
is precisely the entire economy which is
improving by the way our opportunity
zones plan is going to help will go to
every nook and cranny to bring
prosperity to this a better man he's got
to make the trips to Oakland Chicago
don't be deterred go into those cities
and although we're gonna go absolutely
it's a great plan Larry great to see
China because Obama's got Mina Biden's
going to take us back to the TPP and
offshoring all those jobs that's
prosperity cycle in at least three
decades that is major great to see Larry